[موسيقى]
هذه بلقيس ألدواز وفازت بلقيس
ابنتها سيدرا في 2016
باليانصيب التي كانت متأكدة من
أنها ستغير حياتها
[موسيقى]
كانت متزوجة حديثًا تعيش في اليمن
في عامها الرابع بالجامعة
وسرعان ما ستصبح
حاملًا عندما علمت  لقد فازت في
يانصيب تأشيرة التنوع للولايات المتحدة
والمعروف أيضًا باسم يانصيب البطاقة الخضراء ،
يانصيب تأشيرة التنوع هو
برنامج تم توقيعه ليصبح قانونًا بواسطة جورج إتش دبليو
بوش كجزء من
قانون الجنسية للهجرة لعام
1990 ، وهو الإصلاح الأكثر شمولاً
لقوانين الهجرة لدينا
في 66 عامًا ويهدف البرنامج الآن
إلى زيادة
المهاجرين من البلدان التي
لا يوجد فيها عادةً الكثير من الأفراد القادمين
إلى الولايات
المتحدة ، وهو إضافة إلى التنوع العرقي
للولايات المتحدة.
يانصيب تأشيرة التنوع لعام 2017
الذي يمنح ما يصل إلى 50000 تأشيرة كل
عام فرصها في الفوز
بما يزيد قليلاً عن 0.4 في المائة
ولكن سرعان ما تحول حظها السعيد في يناير
201  7
أسبوعه الأول في منصبه
أعلن الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب حظرًا
على أشخاص من سبع
دول ذات أغلبية مسلمة بما في ذلك اليمن ،
بينما كانت بلقيس وزوجها
يبيعون أثاثهم
ومجوهراتهم ويقترضون آلاف الدولارات ،
وقد أغلقت السفارة الأمريكية في اليمن
بسبب الحرب.
اضطروا إلى السفر إلى ماليزيا في
رحلة 4000 ميل
حيث كان
لا يزال من المقرر إجراء مقابلة
في السفارة الأمريكية على الرغم من حظر السفر حيث
كانت تأشيرتها جاهزة وأن
طلب زوجها لا يزال قيد
المعالجة ،
لكنها
قالت بعد ذلك إنها قضت شهورًا بعد مقابلتها الثانية.
الإجابة على أسئلة السفارة
ويطلب منها الانتظار ، ثم في سبتمبر
/ أيلول 2017 ،
انتهت نافذة الحصول على التأشيرة بعد
ثلاث سنوات ونصف ،
تعيش بيلكيس في إسطنبول
مع ابنتها سيدرا البالغة من العمر ثلاث سنوات من
قبل الجمارك
التي فر زوجها سيرًا على الأقدام إلى أوروبا.
قبل عام ونصف ، على
أمل العثور على عمل في الخارج ، أصبح
عالقًا الآن في مخيم اللاجئين هذا في صربيا ، حيث
لاحظنا أصحاب اليانصيب  أن هناك
اتجاهًا شائعًا وهو أنهم
تراكموا قدرًا كبيرًا من الديون ، وكان من
الممكن أن تقول الإدارة السابقة
إننا لا نقدم هذه التأشيرات
بسبب الحظر ، لا تترك اليمن لا تغادر
سوريا ولا تغادر أينما كان.  أنت
شكرًا لكنك لست مؤهلاً
لكنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك ،
لقد وفروا الأمل والآن
تقع على عاتق هذه الإدارة الحالية مسؤولية تصحيح هذا
الخطأ وإعطائهم فرصة
للدخول إلينا
في أول مرة  وقع الرئيس جو
بايدن أمرًا تنفيذيًا
وضع حدًا لحظر السفر
ووعدت إدارته
بوضع اقتراح
لإعادة النظر في المتقدمين الذين تم رفض
دخولهم إلينا
بسبب ذلك ، ولكن نظرًا لعدم رفض قضية بيلكيس
رسميًا أبدًا
بسبب  الحظر
من غير المحتمل أن يساعدها اقتراح بايدن في
أن يكون اسمي
[موسيقى]
أم
أنت